[Musica]
avete mai provato a non riuscire a
definire una relazione che diciamo così
diventa intima o avete fatto
l'esperienza di non riuscire a
riconoscere una persona con cui state in
coppia da tempo e sentirla come estranea
oppure vi siete mai chiesti se state con
una persona in coppia perché realmente
vi interessa o per noia per abitudine o
avete mai pensato ho provato ho fatto
l'esperienza di avere più di una
relazione di coppia
nello stesso momento sono domande
importanti nella nostra società che non
riguardano soltanto le relazioni intime
ma anche le relazioni sociali
io sono una si colloca psicoterapeuta
della gestalt e mi occupo di formazione
alla psicoterapia va 40 anni sia in
italia che all'estero
allora dal mio punto di vista vi parlerò
della coppia secondo un aspetto
importante è ancora poco esplorato che
la sincronia cioè il modo di essere di
essere in coppia come una danza con la
con una reciprocità vi parlerò della
reciprocità della coppia cos'è la
sincronia la sincronia e la capacità di
rispondere all'altro in un tempo
abbastanza breve da creare una ritmicità
del uno con l'altro quindi da creare una
danza la sincronia quindi è qualcosa che
oggi è importante e nasce già nelle
relazioni primarie già nelle prime
relazioni dei genitori con i bar con il
bambino dai primi giorni di vita si darà
avvio a quella che poi sarà la sincronia
o la reciprocità nelle relazioni del
bambino
in più c'è sincronia e più c'è il senso
e il bambino riesce a regolare la rouse
al cioè la crescita dell'eccitazione
nelle cose che fa sia che siano
accompagnate da paura o da gioia i
vocalizzi della mamma calmano il bambino
e lo fanno radicare anche nella
relazione più c'è sincronia e più c'è il
senso dell'alleanza in una relazione
successi in cromia più c'è il senso
della della sicurezza di sé quindi la
sincronia consente di essere più sicuri
di essere più radicati in se stessi e
anche di poter affrontare le situazioni
stressanti della vita in un modo
autonomo
tutte le ricerche psicologiche e neuro
scientifiche in questi anni ci portano a
descrivere le relazioni come come
relazioni in cui noi il nostro se nasce
cresce all'interno appunto di relazioni
significative il nostro cervello è fatto
nella relazione e per la relazione e in
particolare sembra che il nostro
cervello sia sensibile al movimento
dell'altro
il bambino per esempio riconoscere la
madre non tanto dai singoli dettagli del
volto ma da tutto l'insieme dei dettagli
che vengono armonizzati in un movimento
quindi noi siamo sensibili all'armonia
in movimento dell'altro e anche noi
rispondiamo al movimento dell'altro con
un nostro movimento ci intenzioni hanno
verso l'altro in un modo creativo quindi
dando luogo ad una danza unica che è
fatta del movimento dell'altro e il
movimento nostro questo questo movimento
quindi è la sede della danza della
coppia della reciprocità ma anche la
sede della nascita del se noi lasciamo
il nostro 6 nasce cioè il senso di chi
siamo nasce all'interno di relazioni
significative ma in più possiamo dire
che nasce anche all'interno di nuovi di
un movimento
cioè del movimento che si apprende
all'interno della relazione come cosa
cambia questo nel nostro modo di
guardare la coppia
cambia il fatto che non siamo
interessati tanto ai significati
relativi alle esperienze passate della
coppia quando la coppia in conflitto ma
siamo più interessati a capire cosa la
coppia sperimenta nel presente in questo
momento quindi se per esempio una dice
all'altro ti odio se la rovina della mia
vita ci interessa sapere come dice
questa questa frase con qual è la sua
esperienza e soprattutto l'esperienza
corporea cioè cosa sente nel corpo
mentre dice all'altro questa cosa
questo è quello che noi chiamiamo
atteggiamento fenomenologico ma c'è
anche un atteggiamento estetico che
conseguita quello che vi dicevo prima
cioè guardare l'altro come se fosse
un'opera d'arte
se proviamo a guardare l'altro che ci
dice questa frase come se fosse un'opera
d'arte
mettiamo un po da parte le nostre ferite
cioè ciò che ci aggancia e lo guardiamo
con una certa oggettività estetica e
quindi ci lasciamo così affascinare da
qualcosa che ci colpisce
cosa ci affascina dell'altro forse uno
sguardo che ci può dire qualcosa di
particolare sul dolore è anche il
desiderio dell'altro
ecco allora dovremmo essere tutti più
addestrati a guardare l'altro in un modo
estetico per poter capire una profondità
dell'esperienza dell'altro che le parole
non dicono c'è qualcosa che dice la
sintesi la gestalt ha appunto del suo
movimento è un'altra cosa che cambia
riguarda il guardare
l'interazione di coppia come un campo
per come qualcosa che i due creano
insieme la presenza dell'altro è come un
sasso che cade nell'acqua e provoca dei
cerchi concentrici nell'acqua noi siamo
come l'acqua che ci facciamo modificare
dall'altro quindi reagiamo all'altro
risuoni amo a quello che l'altro fa o
dice con le nostre esperienze con le
nostre esperienze passate che possono
essere di fallimento o di successo
quindi tra i due si crea come un gioco
di sfondi e di figura gli sfondi sono
fatti dalle nostre esperienze passate
che poi si riuniscono si incontrano
nella nel confine di contatto presente
del qui e ora che un gioco di desideri
dei due non sempre questa presenza al
confine di contatto e chiara e nitida a
volte cité sensibilizziamo a volte non
vediamo esattamente l'altro è la
desensibilizzazione qualcosa che
riguarda un po la nostra società la
nostra è una società de sensibilizzata
che vuol dire che dobbiamo alzare la
soglia della nostra sensibilità perché
sentire le cose diventa insopportabile
da dove diviene questa questa difficoltà
molto dalle condizioni in cui si cresce
oggi le condizioni sono diverse rispetto
a prima per esempio la presenza dei
genitori è molto meno rispetto ad anni
fa per cui il bambino o meno la presenza
lo sguardo del genitore il contenimento
del genitore
ci sono molte molti stimoli che a cui il
bambino deve far fronte
ma poca possibilità di chiudere
l'esperienza c'è molto lo zapping non si
passa a un'esperienza all'altra ma
l'esperienza non possono chiudersi
allora come se il bambino rimane essere
un'esperienza di eccitazione sempre
citazione e non si può rilasciare questo
è spiacevole e per adattamento creativo
il bambino sì sì desensibilizza cioè
alza la soglia della propria sensibilità
e questo succede anche agli adulti cioè
appunto viviamo in un mondo e
sensibilizzato cosa succede allora cosa
cosa vuol dire questo nel momento in cui
da adulto
[Musica]
la persona adulta la persona deve
gestire il desiderio dell'altro cioè
sinan ore deve gestire il desiderio
dell'altro è difficile perché è
difficile sentire il proprio corpo
perché è difficile stare con l'altro a
lungo da il contatto con l'altro diventa
stressante e difficile avere anche un
terreno solido un senso di saie solido
per potersi lanciare in qualcosa di
nuovo con l'altro quindi le relazioni di
coppia sono difficili per questo
rispondendo alle domande iniziali ci
chiediamo se come a volte ci chiediamo
se una relazione di coppia è una
relazione di coppia o meno perché
appunto è difficile sentire il corpo
oppure ci chiediamo se stare con l'altro
è realmente una cosa che avviene nel
nostro desiderio o meno oppure non
essendoci un senso di radicamento nella
relazione non chiediamo una relazione
univoca e abbiamo più relazioni
contemporaneamente
ecco questa è la situazione e cosa
possiamo fare per aiutare questa questa
situazione ci sono nell'istituto che
dirigo con alcuni colleghi stiamo
studiando la reciprocità della coppia
cioè cosa la coppia faccia bene insieme
in che modo sincrono e come possiamo
sostenere questi aspetti della coppia
che funziona quindi come possiamo
sostenere la reciprocità e la danza ci
sono tre cose che la coppia fa bene
insieme quando funziona uno è vedere
l'altro come altro cioè riconoscere
l'alterità dell'altro riconoscere che è
diverso e non cercare di cambiarlo stare
con l'alterità la seconda cosa è
riuscire a separare l'effetto che quello
che ci dice l'altro ha su di noi
dalla sua intenzione non sempre quando
l'altro ci ferisce vuole ferirci e
quindi riuscire a separare ciò che noi
sentiamo da quello che l'altro
effettivamente intende fare con noi è
una qualità importante
la terza cosa è riuscire a fare un salto
nel vuoto
cioè riuscire a mettere le nostre ferite
da parte per vedere l'altro è fare una
cosa che piace all'altro queste sono le
tre caratteristiche e che riguardano un
po tutta la ricchezza e riconoscere
l'alterità della della persona cosa fare
quindi nella nella pratica nella nostra
parte e quotidiana vi inviterei a
pensare ad una
una persona che voi amate e a pensare al
movimento tipico di questa persona che
voi amate qual è il movimento
pensatelo e quando avete tempo magari
disegnate lo in altre cose che potete
fare per capire la sincronia della
vostra relazione di coppia e chiedete ad
un amico di guardarvi mentre voi
decidete qualcosa insieme per esempio
dove andare in vacanza e poi chiedetegli
di dirvi cosa beh come vede la vostra
relazione come vede la vostra danza come
la descriverebbe da un punto di vista
estetico
un'altra cosa che potete fare è trovare
insieme due tre cose che sapete fare
bene e poi chiedervi che cosa sento
quando faccio questa cosa bene insieme
all'altro per esempio fare la spesa una
cosa molto banale quando faccio la spesa
cole 2000 faccio bene perché mi sento
libera penso di poter scegliere anche
quello che voglio pensate adesso il
momento difficile cosa dovrebbe fare
l'altro perché voi possiate sentirvi
così bene perché voi possiate sentirvi
liberi per esempio l'altro dovrebbe
farvi un sorriso o dovrebbe dirgli
quella frase che mi fa sentire libera è
così riuscita a individuare questa cosa
magica che la persona può fare con voi è
un grande aiuto è una terza cosa che
potete fare è pensare all'altro come
come una persona che voi amate e che non
vi ha mai ferito pensate all'altro come
come se non vi avesse mai ferito e
ditegli che cosa che ha fatto innamorare
cioè quale è stata una cosa quel dolore
che la persona ha forgiato e che vi
rende forti vi darà forza il coraggio
per raggiungerlo con il vostro amore
come se fossero due opere d'arte
intrecciate
la cosa importante da imparare nella
relazione di coppia la reciprocità la
reciprocità è qualcosa che è appunto va
al di là dei significati individuali e
può aiutare molto la relazione di coppia
è una reciprocità che è fatta di tante
cose è fatta delle proprie reazioni
personali ma molto è fatta della
vitalità delle due persone che stanno
bene insieme
quindi un problema di coppia non è mai
dovuto a uno dei due singolarmente ma è
sempre dovuto a qualcosa che accade
nella danza nella loro reciprocità
quindi in questo modo se ognuno di noi
vedere le proprie ferite come se fossero
un'opera d'arte
allora l'altro può vibrare davanti alle
nostre ferite come se fossero un'opera
d'arte può intrecciare le proprie il
capolavoro della propria vita con la
vita dell'altro
grazie
[Applauso]